tu as une tête de déterré robert je dors
presque plus je gâche la vie de ma fille
il n'arrête pas de changer les mains il
nous fallait des petites piles mais j'ai
acheté des grosses piles
résultat on n'a toujours pas de petit
pin j'ai mis un tee shirt rouge dans une
machine de blanc le linge est ressorti
au rose il ya plus de vingt ans de fuite
enfin convenablement est un acte plus
qu'héroïque d'élever convenablement
je remercie le ciel tous les jours de
leur épargner cette tâche
pour
tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les a bien séché wwdc mois sinon est
ce qu il est prévu qu'on en parle un
jour quoi du sujet tabou évidemment quel
sujet tabou le nouveau travail de maman
il est temps
grand temps de réparer nos erreurs aidez
nous à faire sortir de l'ombre tous les
supers nous devons changer l'opinion des
gens sur les super-héros et pour cela
hélas tieger les notre meilleur at war
meilleur que moi
[Musique]
au revoir chez les hommes occupent d
enfants pas de problème c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut faire papa le prof dit
qu'on veut utiliser cette méthode je
connais pas cette méthode est pourquoi
ils chargent les matches les maps et les
maths et m'a fait très mal au cou série
commence très bien j'espère
c'est soit la petite de l'instance et
jacquet est très en forme c'est quoi ça
ok tiens tiens voici bloqués waouh
d'accord ça c'est flippant c'est
complètement fou non pour aider ma
famille et je dois la quitte t il pour
faire régner la loi pour la transgresser
pour nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le choix
[Musique]
combustion imminent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
l'hypnotiseur antero ce programme afin
de vous délivrer un message en film en
costumes ça m'a chauffé
j'arrive tu me dépêcher
[Musique]